qui est à l'origine du wifi aujourd'hui
je vous parle d'une femme extraordinaire
hedy lamarr elle un parcours
extraordinaire né en 1914 à vienne est
vide et vac isler veut devenir actrice
elle y arrive direction hollywood elle
se fait appeler est dit lamar et tourne
avec les plus grands prédit la mare est
aussi une femme de science pendant la
seconde guerre mondiale elle dépose un
brevet pour un système de communication
secret destiné aux sous marins il permet
aux torpille radioguidés d'être presque
indétectable par l'aisne malheureusement
elle n'est pas prise au sérieux par
l'armée américaine qui juge son idée il
réalisable il faut attendre vingt ans
pour que son invention sont utilisés
lors de la crise de cuba et encore 20
ans de plus pour que les fabricants
d'électronique la développer à leur tour
ce système de communication est à la
base de notre wii fit actuel et du gps
il est encore utilisée pour positionner
les satellites ou les téléphones
portables